I'm going to say the most my anime list
anime man thing ever I love
[Music]
this what did you think I was going to I
just had that Robert Downey Jr like oh
my
God hello everyone welcome back to
another episode of trash taste I'm your
host Joey and I'm with my weeb friends
Connor and Gant because today we are
going to be talking about anime how on
brand that the anime man is hosting the
anime episode of trash taste said no one
so JY what are we doing today today uh
we're going to be doing something very
very simple you guys might know of a
website called My anime list you know
pretty well used by the online anime
Community but did you know that my anime
list is not only a website that is used
to catalog the shows you've watched or
but ALS this is not an ad by the way I
feel like I'm in an anime man video
right now I'm just good at explaining
holy [__] Joey still got it Joey still
got it my anime list is not just the
website where you can like catalog shows
you've watched dropped plan to watch all
that kind of stuff but they also have
lists that are based on uh Community
popularity uh so today we decided we're
going to be going to the my anime list
top 50 uh anime series of all time
according to the people on my anime list
and uh see if we agree or disagree with
what is on this list cuz uh we all have
I'm already I'm already like what the fu
we all have differing opinions on it and
this list does change quite frequently
yeah I haven't seen this list in a very
very long time I have not seen this list
in a very very long time either so we
decided to begin with we're going to
start with the top rated and then uh see
what the most and then after we go
through the top rated we'll see what the
most popular ones are and see see if
there's any correlation between the top
rated anime list of all time and the
most popular anime of all time oh no no
so I was going to say like to to discern
the difference top rated is basically
people can vote uh out of like 10 stars
of like how good they're you know they
thought the shows were and then they
take the total average of that of
everyone who voted on it and then put it
on a top 50 most popular is people can I
think on my anime list there's like a
list of like where people can add anime
to like their favorite shows and it's
based on how many people how many users
put it in their favorite shows list so
it's a little bit different okay so I
think for the top rated I think we
should go through the list and see what
our ratings would be after we discuss it
to see let see if we agree or disagree
or disagree I'm saying this thank God
I'm wearing this comfortable ass merch
for this list CU otherwise I don't know
if I'd be ready to throw some heat I
think it's off thing mer is on store
anymore oh it's oh yeah F but if you
were there when you were when it was
available then you'll know how amazing
this stuff why do we have it everywhere
then uh you know just cuz it looks sick
okay just looks good but don't worry
there'll be more merch to come uh in the
future so uh let's go let's check out
this top anime series list um already
already I I'm about to throw hands can I
say that I this is my least favorite
Trend in the anime Community when they
when people like a show a lot a new show
is airing like let's get it to the top
of my anime list let's all let's all go
and write 10 Stars uh and all it does is
invite people to be like you guys are
[__] idiots yeah no I feel like
here's here's the marketing strp right
you uh you you make a new anime how do
you gain hype you make a bunch of bots
because at the time of this recording uh
so freen has not finished airing about
episodes about halfway through at the
time of this recording how the [__]
could it be
and so here here's the threat you
release a new anime make some Bots
upvote your favorite anime it gets above
full meta Alchemist Brotherhood people
start talking about it free marketing
it's the infinite hype glitch I mean
that's where we are now so sad that
that's the only way you can get people
to start [__] watching your show
nowadays so do you I mean you're I think
you're the only one of us who's
currently watched the show yes I've
watched the show and I've read the Manga
as
well I've also read theang
yeah this is a great and uh it is a very
very very good show I enjoying it a lot
likewise yeah uh I don't think it's the
best show of uh all time no I don't even
think it's the best show of the year I
would argue that it might not even be
the best show of the season I think it's
an incredibly solid show but I wouldn't
even put it in the top 50 if I'm being
complet what would beat at this season
do you think potentially probably
probably SK 2 uh which let's be real
we're going to see eventually
on this list we're going to see if freen
is number one we're going to see it on
this list but I mean I [__] love
freen I I don't want to I don't want to
like make it seem like I'm [__] on
free are you just saying that this is
this is overblown this is this is
clearly recency bi because here's the
thing that I don't uh I don't understand
where people see like one or two
episodes and then I remember when oshoko
as well I don't know if this is going to
be the list uh where one episode release
and everyone was just like greatest
anime of all time 10 out of 10
Masterpiece they said that about like
chainsaw man as well I said that about
like a lot of the big [__] hype as
[__] shows right I feel like it's a
right of passage for a show to get fully
hype to beat full met Alchemist
Brotherhood as the top rated show on Ma
and every every hype new show needs to
go through that right of passage
yeah but like f Alchemist is the final
boss yeah it really is it's like The
Undefeated boss unfortunately you have
to be afraid of the old man in the in
the job surrounded by new kids cuz uh he
probably knows what's up I I always like
to say that for arham's Brotherhood is
like the Ocarina of Time equivalent to
anime you know where it's like it's this
had like obviously people love it a lot
of people claim it as a masterpiece like
a 10 out of 10 show and there'll always
be like that one new show that just you
know people are talking about more
people are trying to like yeah gets
challenged as like the king but at the
end of the day people are still going to
come to that agreement in the long run
of no but that's still the go yeah like
I think free rent is a very very good
show it has one of the best kind of like
here's the biggest thing that surprised
me about freerun which is you know it's
kind of like it marketed itself as like
a very emotional gripping show and then
it has these Banger action scenes that
just come out of nowhere what it
reminded me was do you remember when you
watch Like A Slice of Life C Animation
Show like made Dragon or something and
then out of nowhere there would just be
this like [__] Banger action scene
that nobody asked for but nobody's going
to complain about but they did not have
to go that hard that is fre like Toro
I was like this does not include this
doesn't feel right in the show but I'm
here for it outside of jit K uh this has
some of the best action scenes I've seen
all year and it's a uh and it's a
[__] fantasy show it's a beautifully
written story beautiful show this is the
top 50 list if you ballpark you making a
top 50 would fre be in the top 50 no as
I said earlier I absolutely love the
show I love the manga I think it's a
very refreshing show especially in this
day and age but I I I just I don't think
I'd even put in the top 50 top 100 maybe
but not in the top 5050 I I would have
Pro possibly top 50 it's too early to
tell right now yeah I mean it's it's not
even [__] finished I hate this why do
they do this I think I've caught up with
the manga so I'm a lot further ahead in
the story so I know what's to come in
the anime but and I I love the direction
that the manga is going in right now but
like I just I don't know I feel like
this is going to be one of those like
solid shows that you'll remember for a
long time but when you think of like the
Pinnacle of anime yeah how can you call
this the goat of anime when it's not
even done right yeah my my biggest
concern with free Ren right now is I'm
afraid that the plot is going to drag I
feel like it has such a good idea as an
opening it's opening like kind of scenes
and opening ideas are so [__] good
and they made me cry I'm wondering how
long it can carry on with the idea of
just like this being like a Immortal elf
and seeing the eyes of like the world
through this Immortal elf I'm seeing I I
I'm going to give it the benefit of the
doubt and see and hope that it can
continue being as good as it has been
fantastic show please watch it but it's
not number one not number one but right
of passage you know let's talk about the
real ghats I'm I'm happy cuz for the
once in our life I can talk about anime
that g
hasn't this is this is okay then
question to you uh since for metal Al's
Brotherhood has been just like the the
longstanding king of the minist list do
you think it deserves to be the number
one
spot I'm going to put a trash taste uh
and I'm going to talk about show I
haven't seen and just uh completely uh
just you know what's [__] up is that
you're so good about talking about anime
you can probably say more about the show
than I can I've watched I've watched the
thing okay can I can I say my
opinion all right so like it has some of
like for its time it has some of the
like best animation for like some of the
fight scenes uh like that fight where
Hughes does like the [__] is it
Hughes that's his name right okay I'm
I'm just going to Contin talk that guy
with see where the the fire guy oh yeah
yeah no oh yeah Hughes is like the dad
yeah right that's Hugh is the dad so
like that was that was like he's such a
cool character when did when did you
think it became [__] cuz if you're if
you're a trash
T randomly say [__] I mean like I don't
think he was [__] I just think he was
like overrated right okay so like the do
mean the Edward Brothers
um like you know they had some really
really good writing did you call them
the Edward Brothers is that not it's the
El Brothers Edward is one
character you know Edward Edward and
alons
Edward like Mario Mario Mario Luigi
Mario yeah it's Edward Edward that's
that's the brother the Mario Brothers
which is what they are called the Mario
Brothers right yeah it's Mario Mario and
Luigi Mario so [__] up yeah yeah the
Edward Brothers Brothers um you know I
think it started to fall off where you
know with the dog scene uh the the dog
scene Nina yeah Nina Nino whatever her
name is the dog scene that was just that
that was like they were trying too hard
of course it was going to be sad of of
course the dog scene was going to be sad
guys God I feel like I feel like I'm
reading r/ anime right now but it did
have some Banger fights uh Roy Mustang
popped off absolutely when he did the
fire thing uh against one and then when
he cries in the rain and he's like it's
a bad day for oh that that that too that
was that was oh s you know as is it kind
of feels like it's like just saying like
when you do a top food list of all time
you're like pizza number one you're like
yeah yeah I mean I guess I mean like
that's like no one's going to say no but
you kind of feel like you wish you had a
more exciting answer for number one you
know what I mean full metale Alchemist
is it feels like such a complete
experience uh in every way and it feels
like it Nails everything it wants to do
I definitely helped as well with
Brotherhood to push it into that status
of like I guess the the pizzza
equivalent of anime where like everybody
likes it and you can't really complain
that it's your favorite is the fact that
it came right after like the original
Full Medal which had a bunch of problems
which I watched that one first yeah
right and so did I right and so like
because you kind of had the not to say
that the original full metal anime is
bad or anything but they definitely
fixed a lot of the issues the original
had in Brotherhood and I think that
whole like fixing the issues type of
thing to make it more of a perfect
package I think kind of shifted the way
that people view Brotherhood in like as
as a series by itself but like I don't
know maybe this is just me but like to
me Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood is
in a bit of a bias spot because this for
a lot of people was the first
introduction to anime right like I think
when a lot of people think of like
formale Al's Brotherhood or they think
of like starting to get it does pay to
be one of the first animes you watch you
look at it with and obviously you know a
lot of people are recommending it
because they think it's a great show and
I think it's also a great recommendation
it is it's a safe recommendation here's
the thing though okay let's say let's
say freen didn't exist in this month or
whatever and full met Alchemist is still
on top can you name a show that deserves
to be not not necessarily one that you
like more but can you say can you put a
show above Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood that deserves that number
one spot that's the hard thing is you
can't I can't personally think of a show
yeah that I I think deserves to be high
yeah if you take away all personal bias
towards this show it really is the
perfect show that anybody can watch
right and you you could have watched 100
shows a th000 shows zero shows and you
will most likely come out of Brotherhood
being like that was a really good show
because it is a really good show uh I
personally wouldn't put it as number one
but I think in terms of the overall
anime viewing experience for every type
of anime fan out there it is the safest
pick and I and that's why I understand
why it's the number one position okay
question number two do you think that
for met Alchemist Brotherhood would be
as let's
say as beloved came out now if it came
out now because I think I think and this
is me talking out complete speculation
uh having not seen Brotherhood um I
think that for Alchemist Brotherhood
came out at the perfect time where we
didn't have this whole not not exactly
toxicity but the whole kind of like mid
era of anime where you know what I'm
talking about where where this is
everyone has pure nice Nostalgia when
they look at for met Alchemist
Brotherhood cuz no one was really it
came out at a time where anime fans
weren't really as competing with each
other as much as like they are now yeah
they were just happy to watch any show
at that point I think it also came out
at a time when the internet was really
allowing uh kind of to watch anime a lot
easier uh and I think obviously people
were looking for like the newest and
greatest show yeah and I think it came
out at a time that was literally perfect
it came out in the in the anime era
where everyone was just happy to meet
anyone who liked anime yeah uh it it
took advantage of the internet it it in
English as well had a fantastic dub
which immediately helped it uh with
Western fans CU back then you know a lot
of people watch dubs yeah and I think
it's it's kind of in the same way for
Lam's Brotherhood I think is a lot
similar to Cowboy Bop in that sense
where like the general I guess nities
and like uh you know a claim that it got
was mostly from Western fans right like
obviously you know Full Metal Alchemist
was huge in Japan when he came out as
well obviously but Full Metal Alchemist
is not talked about as fondly amongst
Japanese fans as it is with Western fans
that's true yeah I've never every time I
talk about people with anime it never
comes out yeah when you mention foral
Alchemist they're just like oh I haven't
heard that in a while you know it's it's
kind of one of those shows where people
look fondly back at it but they don't
it's not in the constant you know
Zeitgeist of talking about shows that
were huge at the time it was just
another at the end of the day I think to
a lot of Japanese anime fans who are
around when fall medal was around it was
just another really solid sh in show
yeah because I personally think that
fullment Alchemist for the Western
Community which is what my anime list my
anime list is it came out at the perfect
time and it was the complete package
which was very rare for anime at the
time um and it's now looked back you
know back in the day the its biggest
competition was probably something like
the big three and the big three were
just fighting against each other on who
was most popular around the big three
where we had and then on like the side
kind of like place we had Full Metal
Alchemist coming up being like hey this
is another Shonen that is a complete
package unlike these other big long
running shownin and it's very well well
written and it's finished and people
will look back at that fondly yeah it
also Al helps that it was only 64
episodes where if you compare it to the
big three it was obviously for new anime
Watchers it was a lot harder to get into
Naruto or bleach or one piece of the
time whereas for metal if you tried you
could finish it in a few days know
because I you know when it comes to the
question of can I think of an anime that
deserves to go above fil Metal Alchemist
and I'm saying this having not like
watched it but only come only knowing
about its Legacy and thinking about if
full met Alchemist Brotherhood came out
today I think for met Brotherhood if it
came out today it would have a similar
reception to something like Attack on
Titan to me Attack on Titan is the
modern day equivalent of an anime
package that is now it is a it is a
complete package and uh you know now
there is a lot more anime coming out
there's a lot more competition to me as
like an anime viewer I think Attack on
Titan is one of the greatest modern
anime to come out yeah and I think I
think the only reason why Attack on
Titan is not above formale Alchemist
Brotherhood in this leag list is because
it came out you know incrementally in
multiple Seasons I kind of hate that
this list doesn't like rate the whole
series yeah if cuz if Attack on Titan
was put under just Attack on Titan like
one name on this list I think it would
be above for medal I don't think so it
would be very close because there are
more there are more haters of Attack on
Titan it's yeah it's not about like how
you have but I think that's because it
came out at a time where anime fans have
become so much more critical so much
more nitpicky with
I think if Attack on Titan had had all
wrapped up in 2012 it'd probably be up I
think it'd be it'd be ahead of but also
again I think yeah and I think as well
like because like you know with Attack
on Titan it did take such a long time
and during that time the anime Community
really shifted to being more nitpicky
you know where manga readers would be
very critical of the anime adaptations
and just getting very you know looking
at the finer details way too much I feel
the only reason why people don't do that
with Brotherhood because at the end of
the day Brotherhood is not a perfect
show like there are problems with it I
think in my no one ever talks about it
though but that's the thing and people
but that's the thing people don't want
to talk about it because it's nostalgic
to so many cu I've never heard someone
call for of Alchemist Brotherhood mid
you know I I've just like I mean it's
not it's a great [__] it's not perfect
but like I I think I think the biggest
like thing between let's say for met
Alchemist and Attack on Titan is for
like for met Alchemist anime was never
never reached the heights of popularity
during that era as the attack on Titan
era right and Attack on Titan number one
had way more competition for high
profile anime to go up against so you
have this kind of like competitiveness
between a big high-profile show that's
released nowadays versus a big
high-profile show that released back in
the day and I think for that reason I
don't think in the western anime
Community we will ever get another show
that will be looked at uh with as
critical claim this Pro of concept right
that this is a 13 14y old show and it's
still highly regarded as one of the
greatest shows I've ever made they don't
have a skin in fortnite so uh and Tian
do so yeah yeah who's the real winner
yeah Wake Me Up When alons is
[__] shling what okay number three
though I've always been shocked that
Stein gate was this highly rated because
I [__] love Stein gate don't get me
wrong but I just don't see it as a show
that has just as much of mainstream
appeal as Brotherhood I don't think this
is mainstream though this is my anime
list yeah so my anime list has has this
this weird kind of thing that I noticed
that I'm sure will keep coming to this
list right certain shows get rated very
highly among uh people who spend their
time on this website uh and I think
steinsgate is pretty much the peak
example of a perfect my anime list
viewer show uh that is true I my anime
list fans are like what Rick and Morty
fans were like 5 years ago where that
like you don't have a big enough I
you're not smart enough to understand
Stein's gate and I kind of think like in
a weird way they like steinsgate appeals
very much to the kind of person who
enjoys using my anime list and like kind
of Internet forums yeah yeah not say
it's not a good show but I think that it
would it's a show that I think would
rate very highly amongst people like
that yeah because I feel like my anime
list is perfect representation of
someone who is like one tier like goes
one tier deeper than let's say like the
Shen Mega popular shows uh so it's at
like that second tier of like okay this
is what happens after you explore anime
when you have just gone out of like Mega
popular Shon but not so much you you
haven't reached the deeper tear of just
like the ooh I'm watching all you know
something cerebral I'm going to keep in
mind right this is this is like a social
network so people feel like almost
judged based on what they're presenting
so you know when if you have list well
you can't you can't have Stein skate you
can't not watch Stein skate not have it
at a 10 I mean I guess there is that
social pressure huh so you we have to
really think about how this interacted
in this sense and I think Stein skate is
that an example where I think if you say
you've watched this and you don't rate
it highly then there's something wrong
with you what R sign out of 10 uh got
feeling go got feeling I would give it
like a nine I think the only reason what
would you put it uh so can we do decimal
points okay fine okay if we're going
decimal points give it like an 8.5 yeah
same 8.5 I think the start of science
gate is too slow yes uh and it really
hurts the show in general um this is
definitely not a show I think that it's
difficult to recommend right because
obviously the first 10 11 episodes are
so incredibly slow and it really have
you tried rewatching it I have tried
rewatching it it's tough It's really
it's really tough even though I know
everything that's happening and I know
the reason why they're taking their time
with it because obviously it all it's
allary information and details that pays
off in the second half and especially
the ending but like having that kind of
format in anime I think is a format that
just doesn't really work nowadays
because people I just think have I don't
want to say they have less of an
attention span or anything but I think I
think I think the whole appeal of slow
burner shows is slowly dying out you
have to you can you can do slow Burns
but you have to really be smart with how
you do it
nowadays slow bur show like what what is
aent slow burer show that was
like fre a SL fre it's like slowburn is
such like a to me it's it's it feels
like such a back and compliment yeah
it's you know what I mean where I can't
say it in a positive but also slowburn
could also mean like hey they trust you
as a viewer to to stay with these people
just maybe just talking yeah oh and that
is Stein gate to the tea and I cuz the
to me there's a difference between let's
say something that's is is a slow burn
and something that let's say has a
slower Pace but is still compelling you
know to me like you know Game of Thrones
is just talking yeah yeah yeah exactly
that's the best of Game of Thrones when
they're just talking and you're like the
drama here yeah where you know there is
a lot of drama there and there is not so
much happening in terms of like plot
progression but it's just compelling to
watch right whereas with Stein gate the
first half I feel that's I this to me is
just slow it's not like I can see the
characters not so much compelled with
what's happening there's not so much
plot progression but I'm not as invested
and then it hits you about halfway
through and then there's this point that
it grabs you and it just does not let go
and uh to me I wouldn't call it a SLO
but it's definitely not as enjoyable I'd
call it a SLO would you call it a SLO I
can't remember I I distinctly remember I
I had downloaded to watch it and I had
it and I I had a few other shows to
watch and every single time I tried to
watch it I couldn't finish the first
episode without being like
see for me it was like and then I
eventually did get around to doing it
but it was tough for me it gets tough
around like episode six or seven cuz
like the first couple of episodes okay
you understand yeah you understand
because there there's so much new
information that they're throwing to the
viewer right like oh we have the
microwave we have the banana we have the
phone right and then around episode 6 or
7 is when you start to get to the point
where it's like is this going to be like
this for the entire series I get if like
the first couple of episodes are slow
and then it starts picking up but when
you get like six seven episodes deep and
it's at going at that pace then you're
just like oh I'm starting to lose a bit
of faith that anything interesting is
going to happen and then obviously
around I think it was episode 12 or 13
that thing happen that's crazy but this
is also different cuz animes used to be
just longer back so I feel like if Stein
came out now I almost think it could be
even better because they' probably have
like a 13 15 episode run and they cut
out all the Bullit cut [__] maybe
they they through they get through it
faster maybe they they actually do cut
stuff that maybe did actually just slow
down the story but see then I would
argue will the impact be the same I
think it could I think the impact could
be the same I I don't think you have to
give as much time um for it to have the
same impact I don't know maybe I'm wrong
though I could totally wrong like like
to me I watch this like [__] eight
years ago yeah I want to I want to get
the opinion of someone like like an
anime viewer today who has never seen
this show here's the thing I don't think
make
it here's the thing we watched it like
eight or so years ago right yeah 2011
anime like there was like the the top
list back then was 50 Max and then you'd
be like okay I can I can actually
feasibly watch all of the great animes
yeah and I still like I still think in
this day the after the turning point it
still would like hit as hard but I I
think the beginning portions would be
even like would have aged even worse
than when we watched it because this
came out at a time when let's say otaku
kind of like otaku culture shows didn't
weren't as prevalent in like the anime
Community right do you remember this and
it was like it was It was kind of fun
the the the big appealing part for me
with Stein's get the beginning part was
that oh it's like set in akih harra yo
that wee yo this guy's a for CH would be
a bit cringe
nowadays he would be a bit cringe yeah
yeah yeah to to me Stein gate the
characters are so [__] anime you you
know what I mean when when
it's oh yeah mayi oh my God they're just
very very very anime the first show that
burned the cicada noise into my
brain the entire series I totally agree
but like one thing I do think I has aged
well is that to this day I can't think
of any or many other shows that they
have time travel as like a mechanic and
it feels like they tie up every single
knot in its own time travel Mechanic In
A satisfying way it was an incredibly
well thought out story and the ending is
very satisfying it was originally a
visual novel
if you [__] feel it in the start
that's for sure yeah yeah because like
even something like you know Attack on
Titan or most other time travel shows
there's like you can think of like some
plot holes you watch it and you're like
H that kind of didn't make sense but
after watching Stein's gate I can't
think of any other time travel show
where I thought to myself man that just
made sense they they they covered
everything I guess cuz it was the only
kind of mechanic in the show that they
were exploring which which really allows
you to get really interesting with it
yeah also they were also they based a
lot of the ideas off of the previous
game in the semicolon series which is a
Chaos Head which is semicolon series
that is what it's called the semicolon
universe so cuz they had Chaos Head
steinsgate robotics notes and uh ultic 9
and they were all done by the same
company and like a lot of the ideas from
Stein gate were based off chos head chos
head is not good by the way don't watch
it do you think Stein gate is overrated
then I think it's I think it's I think
it's properly rated um but then again
that might be my Nostalgia talking uh
because I remember when this was airing
and I would watch this weekly and it was
the most insane [__] yeah this was the
most insane [__] I'd ever watched uh
just hearing you talk about anime then
especially the the semicolon series I
don't even know what that was if we did
trash taste 10 years ago how much of a
different show this would have been Jo
would have been it would actually be an
anime pod you actually would be you'd be
such a nerd
dude dude I haven't brought up the
semicolon Series in a long time I know
my [__] also I will say the [__]
Stein's gate opening still a banger I
don't care what any says [__] hacking
to the gate how does it how does
that cuz to me full level Alchemist the
[__] Brotherhood the first opening
that again by Yi yeah that was such that
was a banger even know
that is that one yeah that's yeah that's
it okay
[Music]
I I don't want to see it cuz copyright
all right I know Joey loves gint Joy's
the only man who's watched Gintama also
is this season 4 or season five of gint
Gintama didn't do be doing I hate that
they never call can we can we gint is is
literally half of this list can we just
wrap it all up into one yeah okay gint
okay yeah we do the same with the tack
there's a ton of gint in this top 10
gint for me the way I view gint is a
complete Outsider and only seeing Clips
is like they're what JoJo fans were
before JoJo fans just got a little too
annoying publicly you know what I mean
Jo you are so right Joo fans just went a
little too much with their love of Jojo
it pissed off the internet whereas gint
fans have just been at the perfect level
of fandom where they've just been
teasing the whenever you mention Gintama
bro they appear the fans they they
mention it and they they are exactly
like Jojo fans except they didn't get
too annoying and they don't have the
dick sucking mem no no no no I I I think
I think it's because gint never got to
the same level of popularity as JoJo did
yeah it's it's the quiet like Army of
fans that uh just every time you say the
Gin in Gin they just like did someone
mention my favorite show toir right
though right they have the exact same
Vibe as pre JoJo fans yeah I think so I
think um one thing I mean I [__] love
Gintama I grew up with this [__] um I
think the one thing I really respected
about Gintama especially while it was
coming out is that over right uh yeah
the manga is um or I guess he's
continuing on a different magazine or
something I don't know the saachi is a
[__] troll he he can do whatever the
[__] he wants but essentially what I
loved about Gintama was that it started
off obviously as an episodic comedy
series um where like each episode would
have its own self-contained Story
characters would be introduced and they'
just be it was basically a gag Monga um
but then when they but then a couple of
chapters in uh a couple of volumes in
excuse me they introduced uh like an
actual story element that was incredibly
serious that actually explored each of
the characters Back stories and
relationships because there's a shitload
of characters in gint but s does a
really good job of connecting all of
these characters that don't seem like
they were purposefully written to be
connected like you know when sometimes
you read a story and it just makes sense
that these characters know each other or
have this relationship and it doesn't
seem like someone has purposefully
written it to make sense I think Gintama
is a great example of that where like
it's very it's written in a way that
where it makes it so natural for you to
be like oh yeah of course these
characters relationships because that's
just how characters are and I think the
fact that a show can be some of the most
funniest [__] in anime in my opinion
while at the same time giving these
incredibly heartfelt and [__] epic
like serious story elements like not
many shows can do that in my opinion
it's either what's up it's like when the
sitcom just has this serious moment out
of nowhere and because it's like a
sitcom it Just Hits 10 times harder
exactly right and I think a lot of what
a lot of manga have done is there's been
a lot of manga that have transitioned
from like starting off as a light comedy
series and then becoming a serious story
like Dragon Ball youu hwo kako Hitman
reor like those are all examples but
there are very few shows that can Teeter
back and forth between these two and it
not feel jarring and I think gint is the
only show at least that I can think of
that has been able to do that as
effective as it did um and I think
that's why it has such a hardcore F he
doesn't deserve to be in the number four
spot I well I of course Joey would put
it there I wouldn't put it at number
four it's a great in your top 10
personally it's in my top 50 for
sure it's in my top 50 maybe say top on
a heartfelt rent how amazing it is he's
like yeah but it's [__] though no no no
it's not it's great it's definitely in
the top
100, show as much as I love this show I
can also admit that there are a couple
of like weirder episodes some story
elements that just don't really make a
whole lot of sense or would just kind of
underwhelming like some of the villains
are kind of underwhelming in my opinion
you know if I were to go into details
and stuff like that some of the jokes
can get stale as well um like a problem
with a lot of the jokes in gint is that
because it was done in Shan and jum
sodachi the Creator makes a lot of
referential jokes to other shown and
jump series that's what scares me about
gint because and so if you don't if you
haven't read any of those or you know
nothing about like the shown and jump
law a lot of the jokes won't really it's
it's an anime fan fan comedy basically
fans comedy series what what what I'm
hearing yeah is uh this is the Family
Guy of Shan jump kind of except it's a
billion times funnier well I like Family
Guy it's not funny I like Family Guy
it's not funny I love Family Guys effect
on pop culture though it's just funny I
just love the
memes so yeah I I love Gintama but I
think number four is just I think they
just I think the gint fans just rallied
to be like we got to get gint off
somehow okay all right okay well next up
is
uh part two we're just going to lump it
all together yeah yeah we'll lump it all
together they they do have the right
season as the highest rated season I
agree that this was the high point that
was the one where I started checking out
as I said in the
episode this
one this one with the um with the
[__] uh with the with the monkey
fight right
thekey of course you say that monkey
fight peo to be fair that fight was sick
as f entire like sequence of episodes
was probably some of the most compelling
pieces of anime I've ever watched I I
think some of the most compelling piece
of Television I've ever watched True it
was it was such an amazing I think if
you go on the IMDb top rated TV episodes
of all time like I think like three or
four of them are all Attack on Titan
episodes from this very season no I
believe it cuz there was like there was
like four weeks TV there was four weeks
like back toback where like I think this
is the only thing anyone [__] car
about yeah and and impressive this is
the season that uh best rated epis this
this is the season that very much okay
let's let's see the top rated TV
episodes of all time number one breaking
B I almost like IMDB's lists more than
my anime list they feel Attack on Titan
Attack on Titan Attack on Titan yeah
both of them from That season in like
the top five these two episodes are
[__] amazing go down go down I'm what
else is
there Titan there quite
in there
yeah I I I get I get I do get chills
when I think of that that whole fight
that happened it was just amazing and
just owin speech and everything like
that oh my God the owin speech is so
good oh my God the the Vinland Saga
episode well I guess we'll get into that
later it'll be out there such a good
episode yeah I'm I'm I'm glad that uh
I'm glad so many t Titan episodes on
here I'm glad that anime is getting its
Hunter Hunter as well uh that's the nro
episode I believe oh God yeah that was
that was I'm so glad that's that's K
Sumer oh okay Demon Slayer yeah I'm
really glad the anime is getting
representation in IMD maybe maybe maybe
a bit too much little too much maybe a
little too much I I don't think all of
this anime is better than every single
other TV episode of all time I I wish I
will say I'm surprised how many anime
epis a little much okay a little much
all right all right let's go back to my
anime list um does it deserve the number
five
spot I think that attack on Titan does
deserve to be up in the top 10 anime
this season in particular even even with
even with all my comments uh prior on
the previous episode I still think I'd
be okay with it up there yeah I think a
lot of people are going to say that it's
overrated yeah I I think that attack I
think that attack on Titan say nothing
you won't get killed I'm not gonna say
anything I think attack Titan is
actually perfectly rated it's it's like
it's one of those few shows that I feel
is really [__] good and actually got
the popularity it deserved it's you it's
very rare that no one gets angry at the
fact that ATT tack on Titan is as
popular as it it'll also like never be
in your like subconscious it'll never be
a show you're like oh yeah attack on
you're like oh yeah oh yeah obviously
duh you're always it's impossible to get
out of your mind as like a as a series
and I think yeah even though I said that
I kind of fell off a little bit towards
right towards the end uh I still think
the Jon was [__] amazing and it was
still very deserving of that SP yeah
it's it's one of those few shows that
hit the perfect storm of being appealing
enough to the masses and being something
like Breaking Bad where it's the
complete package things that like one
thing I always respect is when a story
seems to be planned from the get-go
which is which just feels so [__]
rare in anime where you kind of have a
cool idea and it has like cool ideas one
season and then they kind of like go
into something else Attack on Titan felt
like such a natural progression even
though the final season is so different
from the first season but it never fell
out of place and that to me is [__]
incredible and it seemed like you go
back to watch the beginning seasons and
so much was foreshadow about where this
was going to go I do want to rewatch it
yeah I should I should it's one of those
shows where I think holy [__] it's so
worth rewatching because right from I
feel like I just need to binge the whole
thing
right from episode one right from season
one you're like holy [__] they're like
they're like foreshadowing season 4 and
I didn't even we didn't even know what
was coming um I think attack on TI is
perfectly rated I think should be higher
than number five even this episode is
sponsored by Mint mobile everyone has a
welcome to adulthood moment paying for
rent for the first time traumatic
choosing your own healthc care provider
a PO again getting booted from your
parents phone plan Earth shattering It's
a cruel world out there paying an entire
wireless bill
yourself but with M mobile you don't
have to go broke over it for a limited
time phone plans with M mobile $15 a
month when you purchase a 3mon plan
that's unlimited talk text and data for
$15 a month God damn all plans come with
unlimited talk and text plus high-speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5G Network use your own phone with any
me mobile plan and bring your phone
number along with all your existing
context I can personally vouch for them
because when I traveled to America this
was before we ever got sponsored by them
I was looking for a cheap affordable
mobile plan while I was abroad and
happened to find Mint mobile and that
was the provider I went with they sent
me an eim it was super easy to use and
that's what I ended up using why didn't
you tell me that earlier G before I just
wasted all my money on other crappy
providers I'm sorry Connor well now you
know well luckily for me and for you
guys too you can get this new customer
offer and your new three-month limited
Wireless plan v 15 bucks a month go to
mintmobile.com trash that's
mintmobile.com trash cut your wireless
build 15 bucks a month at mintmobile.com
trash Fe and restriction to suppli you
that for details back to the episode
number six is interesting bleach
thousand- year blood warock yeah so I'm
probably the only one that's watched
this I've seen the first four episodes
does my anime list always do this is it
always write it in the Japanese way but
in the English Japanese way I I guess so
yeah that's kind of weird why why would
they not just call thousand blood arc on
the because that's what it's actually
called this is dumb though you're
talking about the uh the website that
won't allow Scott Pilgrim to be listed
as an anime even though it was made in
Japan they like they like it's like I
don't know to me I I've got rant now but
I seems just so [__] dumb just why
just put it Attack on Titan if if they
gave this name for it in English
officially why are we not using just
call a thousand year blood do does
anyone really need it to be it's like on
Twitter when you people go like bokano
hero Academia it's like bro just call my
hero Academia it's literally in the
title it's title is my hero yeah and I
love how they get like nitpicky with it
as well like they'll they'll say that
about certain shows and then they'll be
like I'm not calling Full Metal
Alchemist like I'm calling it full metal
it it is it is very frustrating this is
double standard with they're like I want
to seem like I'm really in touch with it
and it's like shut shut the [__] up it's
it's called they gave it blood bleach
thousand year [__] [__] let's
call it
that okay so I've only ever I've seen
the first four episodes so I can't speak
on how good the entire show is I mean
you have right yeah I mean there's not
much to say about it it just goes hard I
mean I say this is not even a fan of
bleach the action scenes go I've seen
super [__] hard this is like movie
level like this is like movie level
animation in 13 episodes oh yeah we're
hanging out with our friend he was like
you have to watch it I was like I'm not
going to watch it he calls out his phone
starts showing I'm like yeah that looks
[__] cool but I I yeah but like can
you watch this without
watching that's that's the that's the
problem where and I think that's why the
last St right yeah this is the last and
that's why I think this score is so high
up
because friend only bleach fans would
have gotten this far into the story
because this is like the Last Arc after
about hundreds of episodes in um it the
animation out of nowhere just leveled up
to a point where it's some of the best
action animation you could ask for is it
also true that they slightly changed uh
some parts of the story in the anime
vers I heard that Kubo has been more
involved uh this is all speculation so
I'm not too sure but might be um but I
don't really yeah like I said I don't
really have much to say about it aside
from if you're a bleach fan this is
going to be orgasmic and I do understand
why this fans said I want to see some B
God damn it and they got it number six
but it is not number six it's not number
six is it even top 50 bleach is a series
no it's such a decisive I I like G say
the crazy [__] so then I'm like yeah
what he
say I I liked a lot of bleach I disliked
a lot of bleach um what would you what
would you give bleach
overall okay here's the hard thing about
rating never seen bleach by the way yeah
here's okay here's the hard thing about
rating any Shonen Jump show right which
is I don't think it's fair to rate
Shonen Jump shows based on an entire
let's say the entire run right because I
think I think it's more easier to rate
sh and jump shows on arcs yeah I can
rate the arcs for arcs are so vastly
different and the thing that makes it
hard to review a Shonen Jump show in its
entire
is because of the way sh jump is
structured right ideas and focuses can
often shift where shows can feel
completely different and unlike
something like on tack on Tyson where it
seemed like completely planned sometimes
it can feel like it just keeps going on
and it keeps escalating for the sole
reason of it being shown in Jump like
the my best example of this is Naruto M
right where um where you look at the you
look at the power scaling and you look
at the fight at the beginning of the
series and you compare it to the end of
the series and they almost feel like two
completely different [__] Series
right uh whereas you look at something
like Attack on Titan where you know not
even showing jump but I'm just using
that as an example where Titans got less
threatening but it didn't feel like it
was because it got power scaled it felt
like because the more we learned about
Titans The More Humans learned how to
combat them so they were still a threat
by the end of the series but they felt
like less of a threat compared to the
beginning series and that felt like a
more natural progression but would you
say bleach is in that same vein because
when I compare say the soul Society Arc
right the first Arc to the Thousand-Year
blood War Arc I don't really see that
big of a jump in that sense of like it
feeling like two completely different
shows right like there's obviously a lot
happened in between that time and there
were a lot of great arcs lot of [__]
arcs but I think overall the Thousand
Year blood War Arc still felt like
bleach if that makes sense okay so I got
to ask you guys when you read a long
running Shonen or a long running show do
you sometimes get this point where you
kind of like mentally check out but you
keep you keep you keep like every
everyone has this like some people a lot
of people have this point when they kind
of like they keep reading but they kind
of like mentally check out yeah you're
like I'm I'm reading this out of
obligation yeah I was honestly kind of
like that when I was reading warm
punchman manga I just kind of checked
out after a while but then it go super
hype again I was like I'm back in just
when I thought I was out they pull me
back in yeah I kind of like checked out
a little bit but then I was like all
right I [__] I'm back yeah to me like I
I kind of like checked out
bleach Midway through the not what was
what was the arc that went on for
[__] ages wundo uh not wo I think it
was like at the end of wundo where I was
like I am happy with you know I'm happy
with everything that I've read yeah and
then I was like I'm going to keep
reading
until they defeat Eisen and then the
series is going to be over and then they
defeated Eisen and I'm like it's still
going all right I'll check it off one
more Arc all right it still keeps going
and I kind of checked out halfway
through the espart arc as well I was
just like come on okay I get it yeah
where I where I was where I was just
like okay I thought it was going to be
over I thought it did and they just like
kept going and kept going and this was
the last Arc where I kind of like they
they pulled me back in a little bit just
because I knew it was the Last Arc and
they pulled me back in just because you
know the the action did go [__] hard
and some massive things happened um but
like at this point I I was kind of like
just reading bleach just to see the end
of bleach because I want to see the end
of bleach um and to me
bleach bleach just went on for too long
to me that's my opinion yeah I mean I
read all the Bleach Manga but I kind of
half did it just to like close the book
on this chapter of my life to like this
has been with me a long time in my life
and I'm glad it's over am I satisfied
with it not necessarily but at least I
can say that I have finished it you know
and and it's done I would have to like I
I know bleach fans are very very
passionate uh I can't wait for comments
and I I will have to like I would have
to like re read Bleach just to give my
proper let's say proper opinion on it uh
just because it's been such a long
[__] time since I've read Bleach uh
so I don't I our G and my memory of Bach
is very fragmented cuz it was kind of
stretched out in a long period of time
obviously so don't take anything we say
seriously but six n yeah six but six n
uh G time of the final great movie let's
move on hant 2011 yes yes okay so I've
only read the Manga so I can't comment
on the anime probably like my favorite
anime I think I've ever watched overall
I think I get the hype now
that Hunter Hunter anime was the most
engaged and like most like I I literally
couldn't sleep cuz I had to watch the
next episodes uh it was I just loved it
everything about hun Hunter I loved so
much I love the world so so much oh the
World building is incredible yeah and
the and this anime was amazing I thought
it did a really good job and I you know
uh some some of the pacing in the very
very start is a little slow but it
really picks up right away and then just
never drops never let you go I know a
lot of people say the anend talk is too
long but I really like the an talk I
like the Kim an talk I [__] love it
yeah yeah I I think the difference
between something like the cimera antar
and some arcs like when I think when I
think of arcs that dragged I think of
like Naruto arcs which is like the
fourth in raw Arc where I'm like this
was cool and then it kind of like went
on a bit too long Aon car Arc as well in
Bleach the cimera ant Arc I feel like
there were so many like it it was very
long but there were so many insane
developments and insane ideas presented
in this one single Arc uh that I feel it
justifies just how [__] long it is
yeah and I love n N is a system I really
[__] with I think it's like my favorite
battle system uh in any show most most
definitely I feel like the it like
nothing feels I like that it's not this
guy's more powerful this guy's nen
ability is just so good against all of
these things but he can get [__] up by
this other guy yeah if he's around yeah
even the most like powerful characters
have certain weaknesses which the
characters just need to figure out yeah
I'll tell you one of my favorite guys uh
in hun Hunter why like I feel like then
that was when nen as a power system was
like really [__] so to me and and it
was actually in the C and Arc but it was
like the smoke guy remember do remember
the smoke guy the guy with the
pipe he has like three fights three or
four fights right and he wins them all
and I was like surely there's a fight
that someone is like going to top him
because he goes up against different
abilities and I just found it so [__]
cool that he was like that that he could
make like areas out of smoke right am I
crazy Am I Wrong uh yeah he can kind of
create like Arenas or like enclosed
spaces in smoke or something one of them
was like water right no no no he he went
up against someone who could create a
water and his his ability was so
versatile that he could basically find a
way to get around whatever other ability
that the other guy has the problem with
remembering Hunter Hunter characters
there's [__] so many just like yeah I
think I remember that guy but it showed
that with experience bring it up bring
it up smoke guy hunter hunter smoke guy
H H smoke guy hun Hunter it showed that
with experience you could like you could
figure out how to beat another guy yeah
I remember this guy he was sick I love
this guy and and I just love that it
showed him in three or four different
completely different fights and he was
able to with logic deduce how to defeat
the other person with with the power
system of nen and I thought that was
like so [__] cool and so [__]
insane it was also it was really
refreshing to see a show that that said
hey my world is cool enough I don't need
to have you be attached to every single
character and follow one point of view
I'm willing to show you a bunch of this
world get you hooked on the world
instead of the characters but then you
get hooked on the characters as well and
then suddenly you have like 50
characters that you really [__] F
like enjoy watching and whenever any of
them are on screen you're like oh [__]
yeah I think that's the most brilliant
thing about hun Honda storytelling and
how Togashi goes about the World
building thing is that like it really
does feel like even
there are certain Arc or certain
elements of the arc or like even entire
arcs where like you never see the
character it feels like in the back of
your mind you still remember them and
you're like oh I wonder how he's doing
or I wonder how she's doing and you know
you want to know and and that's I think
that's what makes it so hype when that
character finally appears and you're
like oh [__] he was here this whole time
that's sick you know I mean even it's
like it's weakest arcs I think are
better than most Shen arcs in general oh
def definitely I don't know it was just
such a good show and and I I'm the only
thing that holds it back is that it's
it's never going to be finished well
yeah well it's it's I mean making
portion of it is finished he's making
progress we'll see Morel sometime in the
dark but the problem is is that yeah
that they the manga is introducing this
thing that says by the way this show is
like 50 times bigger than you think
you've been on a tiny Island this whole
time I'm reading it now and the boat the
boat to there is so long there's a whole
arc on the boat to the new place and
it's [__] long this is never getting
finished yeah unless you have some kind
of
gigabrain uh turn back sees you turn on
the whole I'm going to be clearly honest
remember what I talked about earlier I
think I've mentally checked out of
Hunter Hunter no well okay see this is
why I'm scared this is why I didn't want
to start the manga for the longest time
because I don't want to get to that
point I don't want to get to the point
where I'm waiting so and look I totally
get it Togashi needs to take care of
himself obviously he has own issues it's
fine I'll tell you the cuz I do like the
idea of like the Dark Continent that
seems really cool but the exact moment
yeah the it's too ambitious which is the
thing the exact moment was in the manga
there is a climactic fight between two
characters that have been built up and
then I read that and I was just like I
think that's it I think I'm satisfied
I've seen enough now I've seen basically
everything I think I know the one you're
talking about yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and I was like okay this fight has
happened uh everything with the Dark
Continent sounds cool but I me I don't
even know where this is going to go or
when it's going to get to a point that I
I'm going to get like pulled back in is
this a Togashi ISM cuz I felt the exact
same way with you HW show as well which
which one was it with you like when
after the Togo brother fight no yeah
because no what no I don't know what
he's saying but no I I I obviously read
it till the end but like I I think I
mentioned this in a previous podcast
episode but like I just don't really I I
feel you H show kind of fizzled out and
that was just something didn't like yo
chap to Black was like the best AR of
yaka show no chap to Black is the best
AR of you haak show it was it was it had
so many insane ideas and one of the best
villains in sh had so many insane ideas
and then just Togashi just got bored of
you H was like I'm going to ride hun
Hunter instead yeah he he does cook too
hard sometimes he had so many
potentially cool ideas and he delivered
on some of them and then it was just
like I'm done
yeah this this this current Arc that
Hunter hunters in in the manga actually
kind of pissed me off cuz I was like
what the [__] why are we spending so
much time on this on the boat over there
this feels ridiculous it's so long I
feel like I'm in berserk again yeah
berserk fans like but like but like
that's that's long cuz he just didn't
release any this one is long cuz it's
[__] long it's so long and he's not
releasing so yeah it's like I don't know
for all one you thing Hunter Hunter
deserve to be top 10 honestly yeah 100%
I think I we can Age Hunter Hunter when
it's at its peak I think it's unrivaled
shown in I think it just it has absolute
faith in its world and and it knows it
I'm so glad I can finally be involved in
this Hunter Hunter conversation it's
it's it's not a hot take to say hunter
hunter has the best power system in
Shonen in my opinion but I I do feel
that what sets it a League Beyond was
when nen was introduced and when that
concept was introduced and it made like
you it made every fight so compelling
and it made everything so much cooler as
it made you care enough to know and want
to go into the details you know which
Togashi does a lot of it's It's a power
system which I think was genius because
no matter how powerful character is it
always felt like there was a counter to
it and you know with there was you know
we have St and JoJo but St and JoJo
conceptually it just it got to a point
where you couldn't really [__]
comprehend what the [__] was going on
you know yeah it was it was Iraqi just
like pulling a fan name out of a hat and
he was just like I'll give this guy
shrinking abilities yeah yeah to me
Hunter Hunter its power system still
conceptually makes sense whereas with
JoJo there are some powers where I'm
just like that's why I like Jojo it's
just sick as [__] it's sick it's sick
ack sometimes you just need a [__]
Physics degree to get on to like
understand what the [__] is going on but
it's still hun Hunter still makes I
think hunt Hunter easily is in my like
top five anime of all time I think it's
just a good Shonen if you like Shonen
and you haven't watched it do yourself
favor and do it cuz it's it's the goat
yeah kagia summer KAG summer Ultra
romantic which is the third season
of the ending essentially the rating no
it's still going it's still going it's
still going but there was a big thought
end no it hasn't ended what the [__] the
manga is ending right the manga's ending
yeah the manga's ending but this was a
season where with there a big climactic
moment happened in the anime oh yeah and
uh yeah I put it at 11 on your list if
you had a list would be close to it bit
lower bit higher I I think it's an
incredibly solid modern romance show for
sure because I feel like a lot of
problem with like modern romance
especially ones after like 2010 I just
feel they kind of like got into a
formula that was just kind of overdone
and even if it was a fresh formula or an
interesting formula they didn't really
like deliver on it to make it worth
sitting around for like call it I person
call that the Mia effect where like it's
like Mia started off with this like
really like unique at the time concept
when it came out that was like oh okay
this is like kind of a straightforward
yet like easy to understand concept I
can follow along with it you're not
about to come out with the hot and then
it just kept [__] dragging on and on
and on and there was nothing that
happened okay hot okay that is not
apparently it's a hot that is that is
not kagios Sama though KAG no no I'm not
saying I thought I thought you were
about I thought you about to say
yoar this is why K summer was good
because it didn't do that it actually
kept you interested because it added so
many fresh things throughout the story
that is also very easy to understand I I
have a question why do we generally tend
to hold in higher regard action
adventure shows as opposed to romance
because I imagine on this list it's very
heavily stacked towards Adventure or
yeah action show because we have monkey
brain we think that's better and uh we
want to just see big man punch other big
man big man big man punch but like there
are there are a lot of romance show I
mean I see the treat
fruit none of these are in the top 10
yeah yeah that's true I I kagios Sama I
am very very glad that it exists uh
because I feel like kagios Sama is one
of those uh few romances that got a
monum of popularity where a lot of
romance anime they don't even enter like
the echelon of like popular like anime
consensus and I feel like K summer yeah
definit that um is it my favorite
Romance of all time probably not be in
top 25 or favorite of best romances no
no no of uh anime for
you uh I mean this is going into like
personal uh I did like I think I've just
grown out of high school romances out of
everything I think kagos Sama is
definitely my High School romance I I'm
more of an adult romance kind of guy
right now yeah I want adult romance more
well I did I did appreciate one thing I
did appreciated about this season of KM
especially is that the way that they
decided to go about the romance was
definitely done in a more sensible and
mature way where like even mature
Watchers of the show could appreciate it
whereas I feel like a big like thing
with a lot of high school romances is
that it's very difficult for I guess
older audiences to like really get them
themselves into because either the way
that the romance is done and is
represented is very like synonymous with
like that age group or it's just
something that they can't really appeal
to anymore because they are now older
whereas I feel kagama kind of straddled
the line between those two fan bases in
a pretty tasteful way so yeah I'm I'm
pretty happy with this let let me say
like this if kagios Sama came out when I
started watching anime this would be
this would be my favorite Romance of all
time like like like that's like straight
up this like I know know why people love
this and watching the biggest thing that
surprised me going into like the second
and third season was uh so it starts off
and kind of like the the hook is that
it's a romance but it's kind of like a
Death Note kind of romance right and
that's like that's like he he funny
death note Mind Games in a romance and
you know that hooks you in and then
season 2 and season 3 has some amazing
[__] character writing and it gives
depth these characters where I wasn't
watching this to see this much depth and
this many development happen which each
of the characters and that just kind of
like surprised you out of nowhere and
then that's what that's why people
really really like kagi Su um the only
Nerf for it for it for me is that I am
now 33 and I'm still watching High
School romance and they just do not the
same as they used to do and that is not
a slight on kagio summer that is just
that is a war against the entire genre
that that is just a me thing that is
just a me thing so personally would I
put it in my top 50 no but as it's
understandable yeah but like I said if
if I if I was 18 years old 16 years old
I can't remember how long when when did
I start watching anime [__] yeah
[__] 15 16 years old this would
definitely be up there yeah yeah uh
speaking of the most my anime list show
ever legendary show legendary show hero
this is the uh yes I I do watch anime
I'm just not an I'm not just an anime
fan I'm anime fan it's an OVA so it
never read on TV yeah no oh wow it was
it was being released in DVDs and kept
Alive by hard fans well look at the
earring it started in January
1988 and finished in March
1997 is it fully completed yeah it's
fully completed okay um I have not
finished watching legend of the galactic
heroes I'm going to say the most [__]
my anime list anime man thing ever I
[__] love this sh
God what did you think going to [__] on
you you like I'm going to say the most
anime man thing ever I just had that
[__] Robert Downey Jr like oh my God
oh my God thank you Joey's not going to
say hot this is an incredibly well
written show is there a new version of
this yeah yeah I think I vo in a dub oh
really I'm pretty sure I voiced in one
of the how do you not remember yeah dude
it was so fast they were just like can
you just be some uh guy who just said
something in a bar so I like four lines
in a bar but I think that's [__] dope
to say you've been in Legend of the I
think I'm in Legend I I I I don't know
which I have no idea maybe someone can
tell me if I am I'm I'm in I'm
definitely in one of the dubs though but
yeah legend of the galactic yeah but
legend of the galactic heroes is by far
one of the best space operas ever
written I think just does it hold up
today oh incredibly should I should I
watch it should I okay here's uh here's
maybe a hot take from me um I think you
should just watch the Remake is it is it
good uh it's very good I the Remake it's
incredible is it completely finished no
that's that's the big problem uh I I
it's it's actually funny I watch legends
of galactic heroes I go about I think
like halfway through or something
stopped watching it because I was like
ah I I get to watch the Remake caught up
to the remakes and it's I it's a it's
actually about the same point in the
remakes which which is where I sted the
original so I don't have any opinions on
like the second half of Legends of the
galactic heroes but it is it is just
incredible writing I don't know what to
say but can you say confident that it
deserves the 12th spot if you haven't
finished it it deserves to be higher
what I I would put this in my top 10
damn it's that good it's it's like this
just feels like the Citizen Cane of
anime it kind of is it is but like
everyone says it's good no one can say a
bad thing about it I think the one thing
I really respect about legend of the
galactic heroes is that it's a show
that's really not afraid to take its
time but in a way where you because
there's a lot of characters in this show
obviously as well because it's such a
long show but like at the end of the
show you feel like you know every single
detail about every single character and
again like in in I I can't I'm going to
do this but in the same way as Gintama
you it it bro you are literally a my
anime Lista bro in the same way as
Gintama in the sense of it feels like
the most natural progression of how
things can go and characters just make
sense I you like have to have this on
your if you're an if you're a big user
of my anime list this is probably like a
skill check on your profile oh yeah no I
know what I'm talking look I got I got
it are you a level one anime fan or
level 100 an like gint in the same way I
imagine now actually because you said it
reference a little of shown jum humor
perhaps it's more of a like look look
I'm an anime fan gint is absolutely an
anime show for anime fans yeah got okay
go ahead uh I I feel like the real
appeal of like legend of the galactic
heroes it might not be something as like
cuz it doesn't have like a lot of action
it's something that is very political
very deep very dense but like it's a
very very it's not something you can
just casually watch you need to be
paying you need to be invested in this
yeah you need to be invested in it but
no Subway Surface on the side no Subway
Surface on the side uh the thing that's
incredible to me about Legend of
galactic heroes is that when I watch it
it almost doesn't feel like I'm watching
a fictional story feels real it almost
feels like I am watching a history
documentary cuz that's what it feels
like right that's Co um it feels like
that's all you had to say I'll watch it
now documentary I
watch that exactly it almost feels like
you're watching history like unfold of a
certain timeline where something happens
and then every like this knock on effect
on its world makes total [__] sense
and you see different storylines of
different leaders different dictators
different people within the history of
this world things the best way I can say
is things happen
and people make decisions and this
affects everything that happens in the
timeline of this world kind of like
history does you when like you know when
you read about hey this guy called genas
Khan just appeared and then he decided
to do this and then this that not going
to it's it kind of feels like that kind
of like real life law it's it's in a lot
of ways similar to Dune where like the
universe yeah the universe surrounding
the story is so succinct and so like
well thought out it's so well thought
out that when one thing as G said it's
like a chain reaction when one event
happens in the story and these
characters react it makes so much sense
to the viewer they're like oh of course
they would react this way one one of my
favorite scenes in okay last thing I'll
say one of my favorite scenes in anime
is in Legend the galactic heroes where
it's just two these two characters have
just been that have just been built up
for like Seasons upon seasons and then
they finally get to meet I know exactly
talking they sit down for a coup of I'm
like holy [__] this ising Inc and and
they just debate philosophy and I'm just
like this this is sick this is sick I
that's why it's the
go all right like in fate you like that
scene in fate too oh when where they're
walking around in cirle talking uh when
they're all sitting down drinking yeah
but this is this is like imagine that
scene but when you've had like 50
episodes worth of
build higher is what we're saying it
deserves it this episode is sponsored by
Shopify for those of you who don't know
I run a drip company nonsense. JP and
when I decided to start a clothing brand
I obviously needed a place to sell my
clothes I scoured the internet finding
for the best website to use and I came
across today's sponsor Shopify Shopify
is the global Commerce platform that
helps you sell at every stage of your
business from the launch your online
shop stage to the first real life store
stage all the way to the did we just hit
a million orders oh my God stage Shopify
is there to help you grow whether you're
selling scented soap or offering outdoor
outfits or creating amazing drip like we
are right now Shopify helps you sell
everywhere from their all-in-one
e-commerce platform to their inperson
POS system wherever and whatever you're
selling shopify's got you covered
Shopify helps you turn browsers into
buyers with the internet's best
converting checkout 36% better on
average compared to other leading
Commerce platforms I have been using
Shopify now through my clothing brand
for the past year and a half almost 2
years now and I haven't had a single
problem with it the way to operate it is
smooth all of the data is presented
beautifully and cleanly so that it's
easy to understand for someone that's
dumb dumb like me and the amount of
customization you can do as well is just
absolutely fluid and amazing as well so
sign up for a $1 per month trial period
at shopify.com sltr or lowercase go to
shopify.com trash now to grow your
business no matter what stage you're in
shopify.com sltr links in the
description back to the episode I feel
like the top rated show is pretty safe
you know we've been pretty safe so far
and you know for the most part with top
rated normally a bunch of users have the
most mostly correct opinion right yeah
so now we're going to judge if a show
deserves its popularity that's right
we're going to go to the popularity list
because there's a difference between top
rated and most popular right yeah so
this list is compiled based on how many
uh us users of my anime list have added
these series onto their favorite anime
list not not based off of like a star
rating or anything like that this is how
many people individual people have rated
this show as like I guess to them a 10
out of 10 I just realized half of these
shows are in
fortnite this this is probably where
epic games is getting their list from
they're just like all right what's the
next one we need to add literally half
of these are is is one punch man in
fortnite is it not I don't think it is
yet I'm surprised Titan we got my
Academia uh scroll down Sword Art sword
Naruto is
thereon don't think so yet not yet de
Slayer yeah Tokyo Ghoul is number nine
Tokyo GH Tokyo Ghoul is number nine all
right well let's go from number
one one we' we've already talked about
this so let's the most popular by 40,000
so not not a lot but uh yeah death note
and Attack on Titan yeah which again I
think I I've always said this I think
Death Note is the perfect like first
anime you get into anime and introduced
I think attack Titan also rightfully so
I think those two are the two shows that
I would be like you want to watch anime
watch these ATT tag on TI is a perfect
starter for action oriented shows and
Death Note is the perfect non-action
oriented show I think you can look at
you can see both sides of what anime has
to offer just from these two the only
problem I have with recommending Attack
on Titan is the first anime is that no
other anime is like Attack on Titan if
you're like dude can I get more of this
like no there is no more of this there's
nothing else like this I mean would you
say the same thing about death though
Death Note kind of yeah but there are
Thrillers but not to the same there's a
lot of anime like death note like not as
but not as good as death think about
like f [__] like kaii or like any mind
game kind of show problem but problem
with shows like liar game or kiji is
that like yeah all like one out is that
like it's it's not like appealing
visually as as Death Note you know like
death note is a really pretty show
that's very yeah a lot of cool Rel yeah
code gas again you know I I've seen some
people complaining about their [__]
triangular face chin I'm actually
shocked that codos isn't higher I I
thought in my head that it was like top
five in popularity okay is there
anything that sticks out here that
doesn't deserve to be in the yeah five
six five and six five and six five and
six but like it's hard to it's hard to
explain to an anime fan who gets into
anime in the past 5 years just how much
of a choke hold sword. online has at at
Peak when sword online came out it was
like the only show oh yeah it was the
only thing anyone [__] spoke about
and it dominated online culture because
there just wasn't as much anime out
there's no shows about the real ones The
Gamers out there I think people hey man
don't discredit my boy dot hack like
that all
right the [__] out hack did it
first if I wanted to watch a camping
anime I'd watch your Camp okay cuz
that's what dot hack was it was a it's
not a gamer anime a camp it wasn't for
the male fantasy Joey and sort online is
for the male fantasy you want to log
into you want to be the god gamer it's
sort out online this show was so [__]
popular not so much now thank God but it
was in it was ridiculous how popular
this show I got to ask it would be in
fortnite if it came out today Jo Joe I I
got to ask Jo all right personal
question yeah did watched SW ass online
before it got popular yeah and you had
formed your opinion about it yeah as
yeah yeah not not based not based on any
it's okay it's okay to say you didn't
like it no no no no I I I I remember
dude this is this is a really like no
this is a really well-known meme in my
community that when I was writing anime
reviews on my website before I even
started making videos I gave the first
season of sort online a 9 out of 10 did
you actually yeah it's it's a and and
this is a and this is something that I
have owned up to many many times right
it wasn't until oh my God the biggest
plot TST yeah it wasn't until the second
season came out right Al online or I
guess the second half of the first
season came out that I started to see
issues and then it made me rewatch from
the beginning to be like was I just
being swallowed up by the hype of the
show and then I started to pinpoint all
the problems and I'm like ah I think I
was just blinded by the hype of this
show I've never seen a show fumble
season 2 so much oh my God yeah alame
was the biggest fumble and it fumbled so
hard that it made me question if actual
like the first half of I distinctly
remember watching s online season one
and I thought holy [__] it's a show for
me it's a show that gets me and my my in
my like innate desires okay I will give
sord online credit in saying that I
think the first two episodes of sld
online season one was good no legit I
think first two episodes of Saw on line
I think had a lot of potential to go in
a direction that would have been a lot
more interesting I [__] Lov season
one I I had a great time with it uh I I
still think go go but yeah season 2 was
such [__] dog [__] yeah season so
yeah I don't know why
everyone everyone liked Sword Art Online
until they didn't and I just you know
the moment I checked out when just when
they started making a family I was like
what the [__] is this what the [__] is
this I checked out was when yui that
[__]
small that was the point where I was
like you've gone in the wrong direction
I was like if I okay if I'm playing this
game if I'm in this game I'm selling
that thing for XP or or I'm finding a
way to make use of this kid I'm not
[__] raising it what the [__] that
was the moment where like all logic was
thrown out the window and it just took
the story in a direction like cuz the
concept of sort out online could have
gone in like a really dark and brooding
Direction where like you could actually
feel the stakes of like like these
characters that were put in place right
but it took itself in a direction where
it didn't really highlight that like
Doom and Gloom that the world was built
around and instead focused on like so
how the [__] can I RIS up ARA like like
no one gives a [__] like you completely
forgot about the whole point of the
story that you placed your characters in
and put in some [__] romance story
behind it and it just ruined everything
by cuz he he wrote asa's very boring
generally and then gave up on ASA and
was like let's just introduce new girls
[__] all right yeah I mean I think it's
it's interesting right because I look
back to sword outline season one and I
generally think that there were some
really cool ideas in season one I think
we I think we I think a lot of we again
first couple of episodes introduced so
many cool ideas that could have been
used in so many interesting ways in the
story and then Kahari was just like yeah
but I really want as K to [__] like
that's all he cared about well I I think
and that's what all the viewers cared
about apparently yeah I mean the boss
battles in Sword outs online it's still
[__] hype of yes it's [__] power
fantasy but I remember seeing Kyo get
the [__] second sword out didn't
really think too much about how fair
this was as a game mechanic that the one
person also how much it didn't make
sense yeah yeah I I at the point if it
was a real game it'd be [__] stupid
be like what a [__] dumb mechanic
yeah exactly well that guy gets two
swords because he has quick reaction
times [__] that guy what the [__] yeah
that just makes Faker even more [__]
op what the [__] man yeah but that's the
thing right is that like like you know
and when I initially went back to
rewatch it and I started to like
actually dissect the show for what it
was and I realized this could have gone
in a direction that I would have really
thoroughly enjoyed and you know
subsequent shows after sord online came
out actually did go in directions that
were interesting and actually utilize
the story in the way that it was
intended to be like Log Horizon for
example where as s on line I feel the
biggest sin that s online committed was
that it just fumbled a really
interesting idea I I I think I think Log
Horizon fumbled it too you think I feel
like it just couldn't figure out what it
wanted to do I think it was in a better
trajectory than it was though I I did
Peak blog Horizon I enjoyed more than
than Peak sort out online for me I felt
like lyson also kind of was
like what do I want this to be now I
don't know but but sort out online yeah
it was insane when it came out and I'm
not surprised that it's number five
however I mean such an easy show to
recommend still going to defend Alice's
though I'm still going to
defend I think the longer time passes
the more we'll see sort of online slowly
drop down because you know people aren't
really I don't think as many people are
watching it anymore no no there's people
like me trash people watching I feel
like it's going to become an old
internet meme in like 20 years like oh
SW online is so
bad uh W pun man being number four
though uh I do agree with that I think
it I think it [__] season one yeah
season one was such a
I came out of [__] nowhere and just
kind of like it was and it was one of
those shows where I could I could easily
again recommend it to anyone be like
just check it out it's I'm going to be
that guy you don't think it's that good
I'm going to be that guy uh Mob pyer
deserves the spot mob deserves this spot
what I think when we're talking about
popularity right we have to think if
you're a an anime fan who's got five
anime to watch and then then you're
clocking out of anime you're done you've
done your we're not we're not we're not
arguing if we understand the popularity
cuz I understand the popularity does it
deserve this much popularity I'm saying
yeah I mean mob definitely deserves it
but mob is also a show that you watch
after you've already watch like 20 anime
I will argue this point once I will
argue this point once I figure out what
placement mob is in this list can we can
we
go where is m m where is Mob is Mob even
there is Mob even there there it is
there it
is okay that deserves to be way higher 2
million favorites seven deadly
sins it's B make a kill what there is no
God in this world okay but wait give it
like give it like a year I think I think
it'll be out oh my God why is norami so
high it's only a few behind well cuz nor
norami you I think you that hurts me so
much that what is Boku Dake got that's
erased erased why the why is erased just
call him [__] erased why is do this
oh my God that's okay um all right I've
never seen Joy this okay let's let's
scroll up let's go back to where we
let's go back to where we let's go down
uh let's not spend too much time on
these cuz these are Classics Naruto yeah
whatever Demon Slayer Demon Slayer sh
Tokyo Tokyo Ghoul at number n Hunter
Hunter this is like [__] the manga
readers are carrying this a no way the
anime is this how much serious question
that how much do you think the opening
song song has contributed to the success
of Tokyo Ghoul like 70% I think it's the
only show where the opening has done so
much [__] heavy lifting for a show
Absolutely it is the the the the intro
is M more than anything else but they
also have the the classic manga P yeah
of course yeah but like but are carrying
this show the the yeah the the intro has
done so much [__] heavy lifting for
this I'm sure there are many people who
listen to the opening are like oh what's
this from oh I'll check that out sounds
cool yeah I think Tok as a concept again
insane concept fumbled the bag massively
uh yeah anime did anime did really I
read the Manga but the [__] anime
[__] fumbled it so hard a what the
[__] was that [__] also also we us
should be banned from ever naming a show
root something it we should I I the
semicolons were pushing it for me root a
what the
[__] yeah that is a bit weird whatever
happened to two was two not good enough
for some people I agree is yeah take
that Gintama fans I don't know how the
[__] you guys name you'll see [__]
dumbass hey I never to it gintama's like
Gintama Gintama cursive Gintama
apostrophe Gintama Circle yeah I think
I've never been as annoyed as when I saw
okay to be fair as a Gintama fan that
[__] is annoying as [__] yeah give give
me a tack and Titan season 3 part one
episode I'll agree on that that's better
I'll I genuinely prefer that at least I
have some indication of what the [__]
this is what the [__] is a route no my
my least favorite is there's like it's
slightly different like working season
one has one exclamation mark and then
season 2 has two exclamation marks it's
like I think we should bring back Roman
numerals for everything Roman numerals
just keep it easy all
right uh your name yes yes yes I [__]
love your name yeah yeah get the [__]
out guys get the [__] out your name I I
I godamn love your name wa my her
acadamia is number six right yeah second
season that's crazy yeah my name is
season 1 is 6 and season 2 is what was
it 16 that that show that show not only
dominated Japan it absolutely dominated
the online and like the entire world for
2016 absolutely it just ran it I think
it ran online I'm surprised that can we
go up to the rating I'm surprised it's
rated that lowy the F the low 7.88 7.88
um because I you know this is before
everyone kind of like fell out of love
with my here Academia and considering
that Demon Slayer is
8.49 as well
for the season that is crazy to think
it's more popular than Demon Slayer well
on my anime list definitely not like
this is uh this is I mean the rating
also speaks a little bit there yeah my
anime list is I think a good indicator
of the western anime community and also
doesn't factor in current popularity
very well exactly exactly yeah because
if you ask Japanese people kimito is 10
out of 10 actually you know what I am
shocked one piece isn't in the top
10 I'm not surprised by that I it's
crazy to me to think that more people
have watched Tokyo Ghoul Hunter Hunter
Naruto I'm not surprised by that just
purely because of the sheer length of
one piece but hun Hunter is long too I'm
surprised people have watched more of
Hunter Hunter than than yeah I I'm not
surprised either cuz a lot of people get
confused when I say hey one piece wasn't
that like out of the big three it wasn't
that popular and I remember like modern
anime fans caught me up being like what
the [__] you talking about one piece is
like right now it is one of the most
popular CU you someone called you out
for it and then all the comments were
like no no he's
right let my boy cook like there was a
time when people were clowning on one
piece fans I got into it and it was not
because one piece fans were insufferable
at the times it was because no one was
watching one piece at the time yeah the
reason why I never even got into one
piece I actually knew that it always
existed is because no one spoke about it
when I was getting into anime which was
like
2003 uh to like 200 it was it was a
quiet favorite for a lot of people
during perod because the four kids dub
just ruined so much of One Piece image
do you remember that oh yeah my favorite
anime opening let's scroll down
yeah that that's it's got to be Legacy I
I imagine this was a lot higher five
years ago and it slowly keeps going as
more shows popping up Nar
sh No Game No Life at 17 genuinely I I
think J Jud kaon is going to get to it's
going to get the top five I think I I
can't see it with with what's just
happened with the current season I can't
see this not going in the top five it's
going to get higher for sure it's it's I
think wait oh there's one piece is there
is there a Wayback machine of this page
I'd love to see one from like a year ago
and see where ji Jitsu kaisen like how
much it's grown in one year if you just
go by to way back
machine uh type in and just type in the
copy paste the link uh if you go yeah
just copy paste the link from that page
and put it in and then there should be a
ton of screenshots from dates yeah i'
love to see how much it's even gone up
in like 3 months um so you can go down
to like just go to 2022 yeah go to the
end of 2022 so just I still think it was
always pretty like it was pretty Popular
by 2022 and then click the highlighted
yeah that one I wonder how big this
image is though sometimes it takes a
while to load yeah I mean I still think
it was always pretty damn popular J Kon
actually got popular pretty fast
compared to some other shun wow this
list hasn't changed much yeah it hasn't
changed much got
16 oh it's not there it's not there G
scr oh it's 20 okay so it hasn't change
that but wait how much that means it's
gone up it's gone up five places oh
sorry four places four places Sor I
think it's going to keep going up though
I think yeah yeah it's going to keep
going up uh I feel like this time next
year it's going to be very close to the
top 10 if not in the top 10 this latest
season of J kaon uh season 2 has
completely blown its popularity out of
the window and it's in
fortnite that's the most important
that's how we gauge the popularity of a
show nowaday uh No Game No Life No Game
No Life in 17 is [__] insane to me
why it's why yeah what you mean why why
is it so up there yeah bro it's another
show for gamers yeah what you also also
gamers are the most underrepresented
group of all time
also also I think this show just
visually was so appealing to so many
people because it is still to this day
one of the most like unique in terms of
like visuals from popular shows where
it's like who this is in this looks
insane I remember watching this when it
was airing and it was like the only show
that anyone cared about at the time
there wasn't much though there was there
really wasn't no it was really slow year
uh I mean it's are you sure you want to
say that a [__] year for anime 2014 it
it doesn't deserve to be that high up
there uh 17th most popular anime of all
time uh that's wild season I and I say
this as the eai guy um it was a fun show
that that was it you know genuinely a
mystery how it never got a season two uh
given it popular still ask for it today
it's crazy it was so popular like what
did we give you uh a prequel in a movie
form that you never asked for and people
like thanks yeah Japan has but I will
admit recently Japan's gotten a lot
better lately at when a show is popular
they will just make a season two but I
feel like back then they were like n
we're good what what confuses me is that
anime is going through a phase right now
where they're just digging up any show
that had any modum of popularity because
they're trying make more anime yeah yeah
and now and they're not digging up No
Game No Life what the [__] dev's a
parttime has a second season like how
dude [__] and wolf as a new SP wolf has
a remake what's going on with No Game No
Life yeah it is weird yeah and then we
also got one piece 19 that's only going
to keep going up as it has been going up
uh silent Voice number 20 I hate my
anime list I hate that you do this why
just put silent voice we're in English
why I don't understand in Japan it's
called
qu uh and then we got C season one okay
do you think codas still deserves the
popularity yeah that that I got that I'm
I'm honestly kind of shocked that it's
not higher it must have fallen recently
uh as less people probably get into it
yeah yeah I mean it's pretty old right
now yeah go to the uh yeah where is it
at on this list uh yeah it 19 no no it
it went down did it yeah went down go
back up yeah it's yeah well yeah because
it's an old anime right yeah yeah um I
think I'm try I'm trying to think would
I how much how much is this Nostalgia
talking oh I have I have an un unbridled
amount of nostalgia for the show I this
oh this show just makes me feel happy
when I see it just such a good time it
was like it was like Peak like Xbox era
2 and I'm like when I watched I would
say I would say if I had to say anything
I think the only thing that is not age
well with code guas is potentially the
visuals and like the character designs
it is very mid 2000s I love it I love
the [__] that's the thing though it's
it's very like U it's very like uh
divisive on like some I've heard some
people say like the visuals for K yes
are amazing I've heard a lot of people
say they don't like the visuals for code
gas um but in terms of like how the
story was written and you know all of
the great things that made K such a
great story I think it still holds up it
was the first time I had to start like
checking my doors were shut before I
watched it CU there would just be random
shots of like also the that was that was
uh Season Two Season Two just got
randomly way more horny than SE I like
hold up why am I also I will say the
blatant Pizza Hut ads uh in the middle
of each episodes were a bit weird even
back then all right all right I I I got
to say this okay I'm not sure Cod Gas is
as good as we remember it all right 100%
100% I I have I have rewatched it right
and you know we we we all Remember That
season 2 [__] mess right season one
though perfect perfect show in my
mind almost perfect show was that one
episode with the cat I was going to okay
okay there one episode with cat do we do
we remember the Cat episode I remember
do we remember the whole uh ma Arc yeah
that was weird too I don't remember that
you wiped it from your M you you WIP I
might have wiped it from my m
you do you remember when this other
random guy with a gas just kidnapped
nanal and [__] with I do remember that I
was just like that was a thing that
happened and oh my God never I think I
guess I did wipe that from my memory
holy [__] yeah I do remember that yeah I
remember rewatching uh code GS with
Sydney like a few years ago uh cuz she'd
never seen it and she still [__]
loves the ending and everything but I
think watching it monay you forget that
there are maybe filler is not the no I
think it is filler there is a lot lot of
things lot of Random Encounters a lot of
bloat and also there is this point that
I don't know why I thought this was like
a [__] genius plot twist when I
watched this when I was like 17 or
whatever um but if you remember the end
of there was something that happened at
the end of season it's nearly a
20-year-old show I think it's F there is
this point where code gas had ended it's
it solved all his conflicts like
euphemia was going to be like hey it's
okay I'm going to give up the throne or
whatever I can't remember the exact
thing but I remember all of like the
conflicts had been solved and then L
just
goes like if I hypothetically said told
you to go murder everyone oh yeah that
was so [__] funny if I just
hypothetically told you to go murder
everyone you do it and then out of like
sheer coincident he had awoken a second
gas and I'm just like I I remember
watching this as an adult I was just
like huh that feels kind of of
bullshitty
doesn't time I must have been like ain't
no way but like now I probably like i'
watch it like that's [__] dumb he's
got
two when he said water eia at the
perfect time and she starts murdering
and now the plot continues and then
there's a season two now yeah that is
that is kind of weird yeah yeah yeah um
so yeah no maybe I I think Nostalgia is
carrying this to me one I think I think
I like it at I still think it has the
best ending in anime period I I just
think that if it aired nowadays probably
we'd be calling out some of its let's
say you inconsistencies inconsistencies
even with season one uh Tora yeah I'm
happy with Tora at this part I think
it's my favorite romance anime I I
prefer golden time
gold you're a real one you're a real
with you
guys talking romance shows from the same
author golden time I think just like I
for I always forget about Golden time
golden time is my favorite romance anime
of all time episode I think I even said
I and I I say this fully acknowledging
that uh ghost banry was a thing that I
would like to wipe for my memory do you
remember ghost
banry good let let's I have to rewatch
golden time let's keep it that do you
know remember so we agree that we like
this spot but we swap it with golden
time I would swap to with gold you think
like 23rd for Golden time is
chill wait why do I recognize this show
that's golden time golden time oh so
ghost banry was a side plot that uh in
theime was yes oh my God I do remember
this cuz it was so [__] we had just
wiped this side plot from all of our
memories and this is the one blight
that's bringing down golden time for me
a what is that Hunter Hunter edit I do
remember feeling
like I do remember feeling the [__]
cult thing was weird but I liked it I
don't know I I I think I think part
let's continue with the L we like golden
time
golden this is the violin why y l in
April 24 for God's sake you I
hit look at this rezero title what the
[__] can you can you read that
re very good we rezero for short uh okay
you're l in April I I have a bias
towards this show because I love shows
about music and as someone who did
classical piano
like the soundtrack to it is [__]
awesome and I think it did a lot of
really good things uh the
ending was a bit whack I will say it
wasn't the ending it was halfway through
halfway through it was halfway through
which part it's like episode 14 I think
I don't remember okay I I I will I will
tell you this Jory because I really
really liked your line and April and I
thought I I really [__] like the
music aspect of that um and then at some
point it just felt like it just gave up
in that aspect and was just and it was
like the writer thought hey this isn't
sad enough seeing someone deal with the
trauma of rediscovering Music we need we
need [__] cancer or some [__] we need
a real death yeah and that to me uh
after that tonal shift that I I kind of
like just checked out because it almost
felt I yeah it it almost felt like a
little bit too forced where I was really
emotionally invested in uh I can't
remember his the main character's name
of like falling in love or rediscovering
his love for music and all the trauma
that he went through I was like really
emotionally invested in that I felt
super sad and super happy when seeing
him perform again um and then they just
gave when he hears the music again for
the first time like that scene is
gorgeous that made me cry like a
[__] maybe I'll watch it someday
probably not cuz it's about
music yeah and then uh and then it kind
of went a completely different direction
about halfway through is this your way
of kind of saying maybe it doesn't
deserve to be in the top 25 I think it's
a little overrated yeah I think I think
think it's a top 50 not a top 25 no yeah
no not even top I think it did a lot of
good things uh but again like sord
online I feel like it fumbled the bag
okay fair enough which is interesting
because I remember reading somewhere
that apparently uh Oda the creator of
One Piece he's he named y l in April as
the one manga he wish he wrote oh [__]
yeah and I'm like Ain't No Way ain't no
way that would have been a very
different show for if you had ridden it
next up re season one um I'm kind of
impressed how much rezer how much of an
impact rezero has had considering not
much has happened in the anime yet I
feel like we're just at the start of a
journey yeah and it's releasing way too
slowly I had a really fun time watching
season one yeah me too I I really liked
it too because it was very It Was a Very
Fresh concept and I felt like they
explored the uh return uh when you die
you return thought they explored it in a
really fun way and in such like I feel
like other shows would be too scared to
do what it did and I really liked it I
like it a lot it was fun yeah the side
characters uh s to lose me a bit though
uh yeah that's about it yeah yeah I mean
also he's cringe which is great because
he learns to not be cringe that's that's
the that he's a true gamer he literally
that's the gamer art that we needed
where like kto is should always cringe
he literally dies from cringe yeah
yeah um so I I think
oh man it's so tough cuz would you put
in 25 I feel like it's it's it's rezero
is is still so new almost Rez is cooking
uh it's still it's still in the oven I
feel like it's not done it's watching
season 2 kind of reminded me of watching
attack when Titan season 2 where you
felt like oh they're cooking something
scratching yeah I'm not sure what
they're cooking but I'm starting to
smell it I'm star even like season three
season 3 out no it's not out only season
two is it's about to come out that was
season two
we only have two seasons yeah that's
[__] season two felt like it was just
buildup it was yeah exactly and I was
like and when it ended I was like
huh yeah so I think season 3 is going to
be the real determiner uh to me but come
on man there's only so much R
merchandise we can push show and come on
bro where where is it where is season 3
uh it's airing next year I think wait
really yeah yeah oh yeah right we
watched the we watch the trailer
together
con dude I mean you announced it Conor I
know I did I did announce I I mean
what's crazy to me is that they must
have unlimited
money this this show the amount of REM
merch they must have sold is dude I
appreciate the fact that they're not
rushing this [__] out either like they
they're cooking and I I will let them
cook as long ASU penetration uh in the
market
is we haven't seen this kind of wfu
penetration L uh don't say wfu
penetration Wu penetration in the market
of wus we have we have
arsena no [__] bodies also uh are you
you think so I think REM REM bodies as
in terms of like popularity yeah no I
think when s online came out was [__]
everywhere ARA arsa started the trend
REM just wrote that wrote that
wave ARA started the boring
vanilla thank you thank you and then
pered it bro as didn't earn it bro Ran
So REM could walk my gosh I will stand
by that I I man I don't feel like I feel
like it's going to cook so hard like you
said that I don't want to put it in 25
because I feel like it's going to it's
going to climb but right now I just
don't want to put it anywhere I don't
think I I would put yeah it's hard to
place I don't think I would put it in my
top 50 right now it's definitely hard to
place oh we are we comparing ASA to R
okay well while you do that what's the
next one just so we can have a look uh
the next one is norami norami at 27 is
[__] insane to me I think the opening
is opening are amazing the opening is
doing a lot of heavy lifting cuz that
opening was so goddamn popular and also
also it was another one of those shows
where it was everyone's thumbnail oh
everyone's profile picture [__] the
guy the main guy from norigami yeah yeah
yeah um it was always you'd go on any
online website everyone had norami as
their profile picture yeah um I was
mostly Tumblr though wasn't it tumblr
Tumbl I'm feeling like tumbler seeing
Tokyo goul and seeing norami I'm like
damn tumbler did a lot of heavy lifting
norami like a lot of style and the time
it came out I think it was it it it was
quite unique at the time it came out I I
yeah admittedly I I did I did have a lot
of fun watching norami season 1 uh
especially uh just because you know it
was just such a fun lightharted you know
you know really aesthetic show as well
but like just it wasn't the most
interesting or compelling in terms of
story and then norami season 2 just
started to [__] drag on was was this
popular in Japan uh I believe so yeah
this is like I watched norami and I'm
like this was a fine show that I almost
have no opinion of and then I see it the
27th most popular and I'm like why how
did this happen why this show totally
why the [__] like what about norami
stood out to get this popular I I
literally have no idea yeah it it's like
it's it's not a bad show but I just it's
just uninteresting I don't even remember
much about it yeah the only thing I
remember wait so that's comparing ASA to
Ram what time period is that this is 200
uh past five years past five years yeah
I mean ASA fell off yeah ASA did fell
off but what like what about when how
what what was the peak when Arna just
kind kind of launched compared to the
peak of when REM I think the peak would
have been season one right so like 2011
okay so norami I don't even think I put
in my top 100 uh no I wouldn't even put
in my another one I wouldn't [__] put
anywhere on this goddamn list is erased
another incredibly overrated show in my
opinion how the hell is this so high it
it it is one of the wonders of the
universe that this man managed to get a
show this high up I it just baffles my
mind that there were literally 2 million
people on Mal who watched a race got to
the ending and went ain't no way like it
wasn't the most obvious [__] thing3
for the show is
insane high it's insane because 2
million [__] like dude yeah I mean it
was pretty popular when it aired back in
the day um I think the problem with a
you know sometimes you're like oh it's
not about the destination it's about the
journey problem is the race is when you
set up a mystery like a race and that
mystery just does not you have to land
you know I don't care if I get to the
wrong station occasionally but if if my
[__] train lands in a [__] crater
and I die then that I would consider
that you fumbled the back you fumbled
the ending you know what I mean it's ASA
not ascar it's ascar yeah
should be awesome my girl not my girl
yeah I mean Ren came Ren came out like
uh much so if you do now you got to no
way just just Ram just Ram yeah just ram
ram and then past past 12 months change
that to like all time yeah yeah let's
see what it's like uh 2004 should help
because then we should see Ashton a
higher a no way ain't no way what the
[__] wait that it can't be right wait oh
no Rand is probably talking about like
the band or like ey movement and then
search um how do you ram
rezero how I don't know oh yeah there
you go there you go the bottom at the
bottom yeah there we go okay so we
should okay oh there we go that makes
more sense okay yeah look it never it
never passed it never passed
Arsenal wow not a single time it pass
Arenal all right I was I was like I was
like sweating for a second I was
like I was like everything I know is
supremacy is going to lie this whole
time maybe I maybe I am full of
[__] okay any let's back anyway
anyway let's get back to the list uh
another one which baffles my [__]
mind we should do most popular wife next
time oh my God I can make a kill you
guys all [__] on it I'm here to defend
it all right all right please enlighten
me it's not bad why why is it all bad I
kind of liked it uh I also was uh I like
did you have a what uh how old were you
when you watch it yeah how old were you
watch I was like
s I've been there how old was I in 2014
July I would have been I would just
turned [__] 17
right no sorry what am I saying I can't
math bro you're born I would have been
18 18 yeah yeah so I think to me I was
like yeah this show is for me I also I
also like that he was [__] the main
girl it's okay I liked Elfin lead when
it came it's the same thing this this is
this is the same [__] I think CU it's
like it did it did it copied Halo Reach
I'm
saying and Halo Reach is fine I I the
thing about Kam get kill is like I can
understand why teenag just [__] I
[__] as a te [__] you think this is
deep because yo they're killing off
characters oh my God this is so deep I
can't tell what would happen everyone
who's going to die next ain't no way
it's that girl it was dumb fun and
unfortunately the worst part of the show
is aame uh she's [__] boring uh I
mean most of the characters are boring
in my opinion no I like some of them
main characters boring
[__] me the main character is hentai
main character material I mean if I
remember most of the characters I felt
were just like I didn't even get enough
time to know them before they just got
killed off which was like the big thing
which was just like oh this is just this
person is just a Trope haha sad
backstory they're dead admittedly when I
when I started watching ARA kill and I
didn't know anything about it it was
just another seasonal show that I
decided to start watching like when they
did start killing off the first couple
of characters I was like oh okay is cool
okay this this might go somewhere and
then every second episode they killing
off I'm like I get it it was the one
weakness of it is that you knew it was
coming because they' set it up so that
it kept happening got very quickly kind
of wish you didn't do that but it was it
was it started strong and I I I as much
as I like the show cuz I watch him as a
teenager I wouldn't put it in top 100 it
doesn't deserve to be on this is the
show that you go to as a 14 to 18y Old
I've outgrown that yeah I can make a
kill yeah I can make a Kill Nikki elf
and Le they're all the same you know
they're all the same they're all the
same talking about angel Beats uh I mean
in some some senses I think this is a
classic but in other senses I think it's
rated far too high I think yeah the only
re I I mean I have a lot of nostalgia
for this show obviously and I have a lot
of bias as a maid Jun fan um I
personally really liked it do I think
it's maid jun's best work no uh but I I
mean I don't know number 30 is a tough
spot yeah cuz it's kind kind of like
it's good but it's good but it's not but
it's acknowledging that it's not the
best right because it is a solid show
solid uh I think I would be okay with it
at 30 but I probably would put it lower
but I think I'm okay with it at I would
put I would put it lower because I think
that I think that's uh the ending to me
it felt like you had a really good run
and then it just ended fumbled and then
13 episode wasn't enough I think it
should have been more let's uh speed off
a little bit seven at 31 above mob
psycho it just gives me an anur that is
kind of wild that
it's it was that popular seven deadly
sins when it when it was aing was so
popular that's it was so so popular and
season 2 when they introduced escanor it
only got even more popular everyone was
[__] on board everyone was hyped even
though meot is the worst protagonist of
all time yeah and then season three they
[__] the bed yeah which honestly it
feels like a fitting end for motus as a
character who is a dog [__] character to
be treated as dog [__] by the animators
uh it feels fitting I never understood
the appeal of seven deadly sins to begin
with um that and I have not watched I've
not watched the second season but I've
watched the first season it took me a
lot to get through this first season
[__] you know what I'm seeing I'm seeing
akam a kill seven deadly sins and now
Mirai Nikki and I'm like ah the
14-year-old Army is strong Fair the only
that's missing is fairy tale we all we
all know that mob psyo should be much
higher mob psyo is good and I think it's
one of the best modern anime to come out
period uh I think it's the best anime
maybe of the 20 like of the 20 last
decade one of the best animes of the
last decade uh Niki above assassination
classroom is [__] wild that is a show
that uh just did something that no other
show did at the time and and you know
they cemented the yandere Trope that is
true and they they did it so they
committed so fully to the yandere Trope
before anyone else did and it was kind
of like almost revolutionary in that
sense but it was a bad Nikki ruined an
entire generation of boys oh yeah oh
[__] god oh yeah it did convince me
that it was like yeah maybe she's worth
it maybe I will ruin my life for I think
Mira Nikki is like the point zero of the
I can fixer like boy Mir Nikki made
everybody forget the ageold saying of
don't stick your dick in crazy it turned
from don't stick your dick in Crazy to I
can fix her this is this is this is the
turning point this is the cannon event
of this like real life law where boys
were like I can fix it from a con
conceptual level what a [__] cool
idea for a show I [__] really liked
it again really cool idea for a show
really I enjoyed watching it a lot I had
a lot of fun with it I I can see why
it's 33 but yeah I mean I just think it
was especially in the second half it
just got a little bit too try Hardy for
me it took itself way too seriously
assassination classroom okay I
personally pretty happy with
assassination classroom being on here
because I think this is constantly
underrated in terms of a show in show I
think not a lot of people think about
assassination classroom when they think
of shown in shows but I think
assassination classroom is a really
solid show I'm happy to have it out
there I really enjoy watching not seen
it so but I've not really heard anyone
say anything bad about it or that it's
overrated it's line to what the [__] we
don't talk don't talk about that highq
this is the highest rated Sports Anime I
guess or most popular sports anime on
yeah yeah
I think I think the only modern Sports
Anime I prefer over haq not counting
pingpong League animation is probably
haimo IO but hiq I think okay the
difference between hiq and hajim noo is
that the characters in hajim are just
[__] ugly you know it's just like you
boxing bro the C are ugly and it is an
older mang as well okay there's that but
okay you you compare the characters in
haimo IO like the [__] it's like
comparing Wayne Rooney to Cristiano
Ronaldo you know what I me that's such a
British
reference it's it's like there's this
one man who has been molded with [__]
testosterone and then there is like the
perfect specimen of like Who had who
could probably be like a [__] K-pop
Idol if he wanted to be you know that's
like haimo versus uh hiq that's true
yeah I haven't seen hiq yet so I I can't
say anything about it I would like to
get into it you know I although I kind
of fell out of it I I can understand why
very popular and I'm fine with it being
there I've only heard good things about
it promise Neverland holy [__] dog L
promise Neverland dog L dog [__] L bro
that's yeah are you serious I did not
[__] with it I thought okay wait wait
wait wait why uh because they set up
this really cool mystery and then it
turned out to be stupid and not fun and
season 2 was the worst thing I've ever
watched in my life okay but this is
talking about season one I'm thinking
about the show as a whole you watch
season two I watched a little bit and I
was like oh I mean yeah the show
definitely fumbled the bag in season 2
but if we're just talking season 1 which
is what this position is I thought the
first 12 episodes of Promise Neverland
were pretty solid is it is the best
written like horror mystery you know
Supernatural show no I only had like I
think it's pretty [__] damn good my
my okay my biggest problem yeah my
biggest problem with promis Neverland
was never the mystery aspect of it cuz I
do think it was a pretty damn good
mystery and has one of the best hooks
one of the best hooks in episode one I
think inime um it was just the fact that
it threw my suspension of disbelief to
its absolute limit like these kids are
12 yeah these kids are 12 and there is
like some plot points at the end of
season 1 where I'm like you remember
what that's possible it would have
worked a little better if they were just
like four five years older yeah I think
it would have all tied together more
same thing with um Tokyo Avengers yeah
just yeah uh I feel like season 2 had
potential if it didn't skip some of the
best arcs in the manga I do think the
manga fell off a bit in the ending but
for the most part it's pretty damn good
all right and we have OG bleach which I
guess we've already
talked at 40 I'm sure that I'm that I'm
happy with that I think I think 40 it'
probably be in my top 25 I think I would
yeah probably put a little bit higher um
season one was [__] awesome and a
great introduction to the series blue ex
and blue EX but this is again this show
was so so popular in the W was
it I have never had a I I've saying this
I've never had a conversation with
anyone about blue exist G I was in the
Black Butler fandom all right I'm
telling you trust me this show was was
was very popular with that same time
Tumbl carrying again was this a Tumblr
show it was huge on Tumblr yeah this was
this was like a really really popular
show uh you know way way back but this
was also an incredibly popular show in
Japan as well oh really this was massive
in Japan when it came out uh and I think
look I don't hate the show I just think
it's the most like okay it's mid I I'll
say it is mid yeah it's pretty mid it's
not [__] but it's not like number 41 I'm
not saying mid in like how do I say I'm
not saying mid in derogatory term I'm
saying it bog standard average in the
middle I mean it's a 7.5 on Mal which is
literally the
five pretty much for [__] sake just
call God's sake okay why would they call
it this what's wrong with you a lot of
people liked parasite I thought love
parasite you love parasite I [__] with
it so much sell me on parasite okay
first of all
dubstep Conor that's music how can you
tell how can you yeah but dstep is the
most beeps and boops you can have in
music I've watched these fights in
[__] narrow to one piece I'm
[__] that
[__]
like um the fact that uh I don't know I
just [__] with it I thought it was
such a cool idea I thought it was so
[__] fun I think yeah I think the one
thing I appreciate the most about the
parasite anime is just how much they
decided to deviate from the original
manga but still did it in a solid way my
favorite part is when he [__] becomes
cool and swag when no I I was going to
say this this did Tokyo Ghoul before he
was cool the [__] all you need to do
is
just but that's what I appreciate it
right cuz in the original manga he
starts off cool and swag there's no
transformation so like the fact that
they in the anime they decided to like
kind of start him off as this like wimpy
scared confused character to then upon
the development get him to be more
confident was interesting I remember I
just really really enjoyed parasite I
remember had a lot of fun with it yes
the dubstep was kind of annoying and I
wish they had gone with a different
direction but I still had so much fun
and the concept was cool Al concept was
really love the con con was cool well I
will say uh I am upset that the anime
missed out on my favorite panel in the
manga where Miggy turns into a giant
[__] so that is that I was looking
forward to that and they cut that [__]
out I would like it a little bit higher
be like my top 30 because to me the
opening is Banger oh the opening is
Banger b I think I'm like the one person
that just didn't [__] with it I I I
didn't dislike it I just don't remember
there there were like no scenes in that
that I really remember or really like
hit me and I don't know if I was just in
the wrong place to watch it I was just
like eh it's fine it's this is like my
norami I guess where I was like I don't
it's I don't understand I just realized
that cow and even gallion are both in
the
40s yeah that's crazy and Spirited Away
H Spirit Away movies don't get rated as
as good
on I am so shocked that cowo b and even
gion are that low yeah I would have
expected them to be at least in the top
20 I'm surprised that parasite is more
popular that's wild that is crazy but I
guess cuz I think people who watch
parasite really [__] fell in love
with it whereas people who watch C I
feel like almost watch it out of
obligation and almost saying again it's
a social media website right so saying
oh c was one of my favorites it's like
okay what else do you like bread you
know what I mean I also have eyes uh I
actually don't some surprised toky route
a is crazy toky route a above death
parade and violet everard fairy tale
Wild W what is this is such a whack list
what the [__] is this you know what
maybe Tumblr dying was uh was was the
right was the right decision guys cuz
then we don't have to deal with [__]
like this I can't believe I I never
watched ever gotten it just felt like
crying bait for me so kind of gorgeous
what
aor crying bait my hot take about Violet
ever Garden is that my favorite parts of
violet ever Garden was the stories that
didn't have anything to do with the main
character um I loved the Side Stories um
um and that was my favorite part of V
Violet ever
Garden I will say death parade should in
for me is in the top 20 death parade
should be way higher should be way but
you know I will count it as a w that
death parade somehow beat fairy tale
let's go kind of I I had forgotten about
fairy tales I'm kind of sad that I had
to remember it right now yeah all right
well that's uh all of the anime
popularity and we rid them I hope you
enjoyed that yeah let us know your
opinions about anything we said down in
the comments below and uh hey look at
all these patrons I'm sure they have
absolutely appropriate fantastic taste
in anime and they'll be more than happy
to let us know there great taste wait
wait wait wait I just realized JoJo was
not in either of those list I'm yeah I'm
kind of shocked about that what yeah
that's kind of tough wow JoJo fans were
like Jojo fans probably like we're above
I think may people would put the first
season in their favorites so there's so
many parts and so I feel like it'd be
hard I'm I'm cop
cult it's really like a small people
don't really know about it people don't
really know about it there lot of shows
I'm
surprised never heard of it but uh Hey
if you like to support the show go to
our patreon patreon.com trashtaste also
follow us on Twitter send us memes on
the subred and if you head our face
listen to us on Spotify also for you you
guys going on to the patreon right now
from this month we actually started
releasing some official I guess patreon
exclusive content fun little gaggy goofy
gag we're not just doing like behind the
scenes and deleted scenes from episodes
like this we actually have some brand
new spanking content for you guys over
on the patreon so if You' like to
support us and check out those exclusive
patreon content then again make sure to
go to our patreon patreon.com Trak but
yeah and with that said we'll see you
all next week guys bye
[Music]
bye
yeah